what is up f but damn what up
happy Wednesday you had to remember that
some day yes it is indeed Wednesday as
you guys may have found out yesterday if
you were trying to download the new apex
legends Valentine's Day events it got
postponed to today so here we are
perjure here max is joining me of course
our apex pro in the office pro I'm
trying
he's better than everybody else here so
that count but yes duos is back let me
just switch my screen over so Max and I
are gonna be playing some duo's do you
guys like do do you like singles more do
you like the three squad what do you
guys feeling there's also some new skins
and other little of belem or is it just
one new skin is it just okay we got
next time gives that live out very cute
I think they might have brought back the
old last year's Valentine's stuff -
which is like let me just check real
quick
valentine's Day is not until Friday so
anybody out there who's seeing only have
a few more days before you can be truly
sad yeah now don't be sad there's
nothing wrong with being single right
live your best life single life is good
take yourself out on a date you know
that's a good way to yeah go out and buy
two dinners for yourselves yeah treat
yourself eat them both all right
shoot says I'm feeling 100 versus 100
well dang nice all right so we're gonna
hop into some duos we're gonna we're
gonna do it we started a little bit
early cuz you know we just felt like
yeah what's this schedule so yeah it's
just duos right now there's no other
playlist no just for due for this event
right it's just do it yes a caution the
chat nothing makes me feel better pre
Valentine's Day than watching other
people kick each others butts before
Valentine's Day sounds about right
that's apex in a nutshell Cory said I'm
level 206 I'm trying to get there I
honestly don't know how I got to you a
hundred and thirty or whatever I am now
I've seen some people like 384 yeah it's
wild it's insane like how did they get
that much experience alright pray for us
yeah we're doing this we're doing the
thing now I'm gonna try my best I was
just telling max about my woes I was
having playing solo yeah duo's you know
I'm a pretty generous teammate
all right I'm just gonna say that there
are
hello
epic guerrilla gamer and Jones TV and
Brian and Dechaine and everybody up in
the chat right now I kind of do once
solos back to though yeah I kind of like
that when you knock something down it
was just they just died yeah no more
knockdown Errol in the chat what's up
man haven't seen you in a while I hope
you're doing well
all right you're the Jonas morning
alright guys like a new map so much like
this lighting it makes it feel new
without it really big deal yeah I don't
like the lava in the middle because I
fall in there all this can I should fall
in there while you're down which is
pretty funny
they give a little jetpack action oh no
my battery's low
after this game I'm gonna run and grab a
USB or if Ruchi in the chat hears this
if my controller dies in the middle of a
gunfight I literally got my preferred I
don't know about this sure what your
preferred loadout is right now also I
just swooped your gold okay now you take
it honestly you'll be better in your
hands then plus I have a level two
what's your preferred loadout oh is the
301 peacekeeper yeah or a 301 and a 99
or a coluan and a flatline I've been
really enjoying the flatline lately I
didn't use it as much until you know
recently it's good it's a really solid
gun that well after the buff they give
it yes
all right cool let's see slacking this
chains have started playing two months
ago my friend showed me this game and
now I can't stop playing yeah that's
usually how it goes yes of one tiny jump
in in there like wow good especially
once you kind of get used to how you
have my first few games I was like yeah
but after a while I started playing
getting used to it
you know shaking off the rust and
actually getting a kill here in there
I'm like okay but I still feel like
there's just a ton of people out there
playing this game especially every
season that comes out there's more and
more fire in the city 99 and a have a
girl sorry Danny still rocking the havoc
right now I feel like that gun is such a
struggle now without turbochargers yeah
oh it's already been open yeah as you're
seeing that things open everything I
know that him luck is good but my burst
fire game in the
and this specifically is so for a moment
I forgot I was in the death toda yeah me
too and I was like no she got I only
have white shows anyways though
somebody's out here I don't know where
they are though so many boxes here I
know but I kind of want to make sure
this place is clear like definitely take
some loot or at least give me a better
shield
[Music]
another part is down up there are they
[Music]
my screens getting covered by the mic so
I can't really alright you go on and
spit fire yes that is also another
preferred loadout only cuz I know it's
nothing worse than was having the reload
in the middle yeah
[Music]
definitely not working out yeah you're
tearing them up working out for once
that uh that silence came super clutch
against that race yeah it's like finally
starting to see some good usage although
people are so saying is not that good
which is kind of sad I think he's a
little slow but yeah I think like people
are really underrating his like sneaking
ability of those that's like in the
middle of a fight when two people are
fighting I just like to kind of sneak up
in there and all of a sudden have a log
star on them like really close
and I think that silence is really
really good the death sometimes just
harder to use because it's all about
where you put the toda yeah you got like
in a really good position yeah it's just
it just sucks to like lose all your
health HP I think of the death totem is
like insurance yeah and like your health
is like the deductible right yeah it's
like you still gotta pay up a little bit
yeah exactly
you want doc she's so demanding Prowler
full-auto yeah I do love that I was like
I'm never comin or when I'm not using
that loadout I'll run into everything I
need for it
rings closed 30 seconds I kind of don't
want to go through the vault Mirage way
I still gets me every time
like it's just fireworks no yeah they
need to take take the fireworks sound
out honestly like I'm sorry that's on
purpose yeah
what's up today here
I heard her pop this battery right all
right so five-speed said his ultimate
should let you have full shields and
health upon death
you're crazy I would be okay with like
50% huh yeah me too like Justin but I've
had your person that's that's pretty
forgiving yeah that's a 200p I think
like yeah just fifty health would be
okay would you rather have like half
shields and half help gun or like less
health all shields or vice versa
would you rather than what does it use
your shield whatever type shield you had
at that moment I don't know if they
should be faster like upon health or
shield I think there should like a
different
to sacrifice I don't know I don't know
how they should fix it yeah honestly I
feel like the way they went makes sense
yeah you know logistically yeah like
it's it's fair but it's not good oh yeah
yeah the only way you can really use
them for position is the only way these
are positively is for a good position
are like not sacrifice
[Music]
no interior plus ultra over time I've
just gotten so impatient that I just
dropped early now yes yeah I've got to
that point too I used to go super far
where there's like no one left in the
ship
now you're like make a spicy next rings
not very close 18 longbow shots in a
dream you guys see a prowler or a hammer
punch you know okay ooh that you know I
had a grinding up but I also might be
tripping there's been a lot of
interesting sounds in this game lately
yeah all right I can fight I can fight
am i picking up John don't want too much
junk in your trunk no no
[Laughter]
I just like looting I like picking up
trying to pay attention to chat but if
it's difficult you need like 100 percent
of your focus on this and even then it's
the struggle yeah for me anyways all I
know of you guys saw I've been sharing
your clips like with all my friends I'm
like gotta check this out is be cool
thing ever
and you'll never happen again barrel
stabilizer here level to go check out
Max's click hop ready all day yesterday
I'm like faster faster yelling we're
definitely in this building over here
hmm
[Music]
trying to be sneaky sneaky it's hard to
do this without being revenant oh yeah
here
[Music]
I heard them zip over and we good
this last max the street with me I was
like I need someone to carry actually
went and they're kind of like all in
because I knew that he was going to come
out of the bubble
we need going that was exact like the
toe body shield here level three
how's the less to me and I missed it
twice
sorry give up keep running well this is
gonna be a messy ring left and there's a
lot of the map coming to one small
portion messy guesses that's an actual
phrase it was like a troll fries at
least bring it near the ring yeah and
then I have metal legs so I wasn't
worried first like that sounds really
close yeah it's about over there
I wonder what happens if I Boyd over
here yeah experiment another game yeah I
just don't feel like time or somebody
tell me what happens if you kill leader
try to avoid you just go straight down
or do you float
I would assume you'd fall but then the
jetpack would pick you up would it still
activate your portal
I definitely jumped purposely into the
lava
let me just to like float further away
oh yeah
but when there was like a ton of people
where they weren't exactly just focused
on me yeah it's kind of yeah let's keep
it close quarters cuz I got to close
quarters gonna steal battery here next
rings far oh thank you
Wow I say as we like probably so many
teams yeah sometimes let's explore this
way the Rings closing in a minute we're
not close top six oh yeah you're right
Bob Jones sorry we're trying like a chat
but also imaginary 25 left yeah some
games can let you kind of autopilot
through this game doesn't really let you
do that who should be savage why I'm
just spin back sir
any other special rules to this mode
it's just duos you know yeah go grab
your BFF and shoot some fools yeah
here as I just blew I'm here ever that's
me and Cod when people are like closing
the door all nice and gently
yeah really weird yeah I don't like this
all appear out of nowhere if you like
yeah there's still five more squats
should we try to migrate somewhere that
care package going on a fighting ring
we're gonna get to a point where we will
not be able to spare any life yeah yeah
I'm not gonna not gonna like that at all
I like being pinched in the bunny hop
[Music]
actually octane can still be like fully
bunny hop he has a similar where's this
ring oh that's the middle that area
let me go to my controller at home like
the left stick is going out so running
is really difficult or inside and
nothing like tilted mean oh I hear I
hear caustic chopped someone had our
idea
I know well could go towards lava city
instead I have my jump that we've gone
through for us you're just gonna go
inside this is well the only thing is
bad about this the the ring is so small
now we're gonna get third parties so
quick like we're all crouched walking
around trying to walk real slow so I
can't hear my Crouch steps you only just
full send yeah I was like you lose
yellow this yeah okay let's let's do for
the stream so jump at
goodbye world
[Music]
and he has a gold shield
turn off the doors kicking it or playing
this game right now ding-dang getting
frags oh it's cool
yeah I feel like that last guy I almost
had him
yeah alright next I got the shield so
like just in time but I didn't have any
health yeah I think that really don't
have been I was trying to pull a max try
right there's like no I'll save this
Phoenix get out enough time I got make
these close calls and decision yeah
whenever you're yeah that kind of
position a full Phoenix kid without a
gold shield 20 seconds of you sitting
there I'm gonna say your name wrong but
Xiao Eve says love from Pakistan
hello signal of right back atcha thanks
for doing this thank you
good try what a game things try my best
stroker didn't know you could kick down
the door like that yeah it takes two
kicks yes she kicks
yeah it's waiting for him to kick again
so I can shoot him but yeah he knew what
he was doing
oh boy is this humor so it looks a lot
like destiny which I like it's free to
play so I would definitely say is where
it said yeah just give it a shot for
being a pre game
yeah isn't a loose
we should learn their father that's
closer to winning each game that's right
that's right Bob Jones oh we're gonna
have so many people over here but you
know what pull it out you're
interrupting here mm-hmm
yes hello Curtis and Cooper
I thought what to believe
when I hear that yeah that's what I
thought too but it's it's actually I
[Music]
feel like I should actually know that
since I'm half Japanese and half Mexican
I should have been able to differentiate
the batch it happens quick I think it's
a full barrel are you 45 yeah I love the
re for you sniping is right in this game
I like never want to stand still too
long enough see you surrounding let's go
Wild West out here
I was actually surprised no one land in
here
how's it you look here for the Eva its
yeah Eva it's here I love yes always
oh it's Latin says dad oh okay okay okay
oops why did I pick up a bum shotty ammo
there's a PK in here you know I have my
good days and bad days keeper man family
some feel bad moments only to like get
totally blown away by like two shots
from someone else's some like either 22
damage I'll be super close I'm like 11
dang
[Music]
all things here
[Music]
anything for you boo lifeline is best
girl like I need this or that I'm like I
will find it I was I got you baby girl
let's protect at all times yes
who are your favorite characters in this
game lifeline and octene two of my faves
I feel like I actually really like
Redman just cuz like he's such a jerk
and it's hilarious I love the like goat
man one paranormal stuff I just want to
get in I know where did I bring me
victims like revenant so something like
when their rings closing at things like
oh yeah the bodies
oh yeah the same guy who wastes the
reinhard yeah is even more hilarious
[Music]
like where's that from that came from
somewhere in the northeast area okay I
really don't want to wing me but I
already committed oh we got another
slide on that side now I don't
oh really let's get out of here yeah
yeah I went on the roof me too they're
both bad they both missed
okay now I'm kind of scared about being
without an hour 99 so I should have
grabbed things there's one and there's a
death box in here yeah okay I'm only
gonna just this once because you asked
nicely Max and I are just friends and
coworkers although this is a Valentine's
Day event it's yeah we are not pulling
it because we're yeah exact scene I was
like I already know for a fact they're
gonna be like Maxine purchasing a tree
but yeah no we're just buds and we like
shooting some pools and it's duos
[Applause]
some hot fire I like you want to go up
like
yeah I hear feet I care I left I'm
rushing him down yeah let's just drop
super spicy yeah I want again to think
of it me walking around staring at
thanks that was pretty funny though he
missed every shot so I was like oh I'm
feeling good I'm going in there and then
the second I was in the air Shh was it a
mirage or was it the tangler no it was a
crypto oh yeah that's my tractor little
did I know the good old bait-and-switch
faster stronger i'm keep playing
different characters yeah I can it has
been rocking out with octene every
little Hawk boy yeah
was definitely you know Pathfinder made
before but trying to slow down now I'm
impatient Pathfinder slow
I mean slower than he was before it
feels like I don't know but you know I
just feel like it is a lot slower than a
master I need to be able to render
because I can't rely on my 8 yeah once
piece definitely slower bring a gesture
will be wind [ __ ] Pasha what did I miss
not a bang here we go I always lose ping
sometimes
especially if like beeping the lavas ex
super hard to see
yeah there's people on earth
[Music]
[Music]
think they're down a level yeah my
actual a prowler nothing
hey both
I mean eventually it'll regenerate yeah
I like that
Pathfinder is very cheerful and
optimistic also it's pretty adorable
compared to revenues a complete opposite
a good thing you guys can't see my
screen because what I visit was really
dumb and there's a pathfinder above me
or and in this building weird I know I
don't see anybody are you sure he's
metal feet oh you're pathfinders
why am I so bad at jumping on this damn
trampoline that's perfect yeah that was
the second time
great already inside it might be in
third squad actually
oh look like headshot Mosley he have a
bald childers like super disoriented
that I don't know what was there was
literally like four teams fighting in
our vicinity yeah I definitely heard
some more and he was alone might be good
over there I'll do it outside of the
ring I'm gonna come back to that side
we'll just bring Annie - she got a
geyser
all three spawn
always right across here well oh no it's
a
it's on top of the roof yeah actually no
what yeah we have 50 seconds oh it's
closed it's right over this building
[Music]
[Music]
watch out what's the event the event is
the Valentine's Day rendezvous yeah do
Oh
so do I was is that I love that they use
the crypto drone and the lifeline drone
as the thumbnail for it
[Music]
yes the two drones of Apex what I miss
who died we died yeah
ding that flame yeah
I mean three teams we're closing in on
you literally there was a guy you were
fighting then there was another squad
inside the Pathfinder was reviving
someone so that was two separate teams
and then the team that killed me that
was coming from like the train station
oh boy yeah they were on their way mucho
spicy
[Music]
here we go I'm the jumpmaster but those
fun actually yeah I like to I like to
keep it hot right in the beginning that
mask I don't like to drop
oh you give you this time
I like Gibby and I like having the dome
for protection but sometimes it'd be
getting in the way yeah I'll be like
about to kill someone and then like
female throw down their dome and I'm
like looks like I get it like keeps us
protected but now I can finish that guy
up yeah it's a it's so awesome that we
got like an air strike coming down yeah
in that animation the revive animation
we have I love that one's great I think
I'd like I'm just for that come on buddy
yeah exactly this is our game right here
I came to win max got this Akash is
cheering us on oh gosh that even drones
are together on Valentine's sigh do
anything again I'm just grabbing all
even though I don't
I'm dark watching deck space scrap that
wait lot of you there's another cargo
bottle oh really
we're over here like they're so
dangerous but not giving like letting it
pass by and missing out on a potential
gold item yeah okay I see we moved this
week
yeah oh yeah
[Applause]
wait headsets mixed around
I hear more feet shoot they're not a
thing
[Applause]
[Music]
such BS let me recap on how much did you
do 84 22 and then 23 you probably I
didn't have any shield cells so I didn't
know I was partially my fault I should
drop some for you
only after I got down then yeah yeah I'd
have to bring that dang oh yeah check
your head looks like it's on the right
side this way yeah cause like ooh
gunfire I'm like oh wait that's behind
me now I turn around and you're like no
the other one
you can change the body
of the game loud enough for ya Rick and
Eric in the chat so can't wait to play
oh yeah
Delos is back everybody's been
complaining to having that duo sometime
yeah exactly
single or not it's here this is your
champion nothing they ain't nothin time
to jump master I am honored
I'm excited to fight you all right
let's go a nosey
I love her her accent - I really like
the way they diversify all these
character it's really fun exciting
recent video
the boys for Pathfinder key interviews
all the other voice actors thank you
like the interviewed voice actor and she
doesn't sign anything
accents are hard to convince thank you
actually and you can't think it up too
much I've been trying to be more mindful
about what I pick upside off the drop as
much stuff but the second you land you
kind of just want to get anything I was
trying to get my med kit out also so
hard to hit Pathfinder yeah I was like
I'll do all the damage except for maybe
the ten damage I need to finish the kill
every time Watson is adorable when she
says that one lion like when she wins
like
I didn't I wouldn't cry every time I
hear that line I'm like yeah I got my
dad to be proud of me they're made of
steel of you want to use Oxana
like one of my best friend's favorite
character really mm-hmm
she always plays her she's really cool I
like a character same skin too
it's actually not my favorite one I like
her police outfit with team Maxo that
flows off the time yeah my favorite like
duo name
all right Maxie gonna brick and winland
why do I keep running to the play the
building there's not a sword somebody's
in here
[Music]
No
I'm so bad I tried to throw that arc
starter and I straight up missed and
threw into the other it's weird though I
didn't hear any of those footsteps
you're talking about yeah I heard her
running and I like yes that's why I was
looting nothing's happening I thought we
won and then you're like footsteps I'm
like why don't you footsteps
yeah these headphones are not treating
me very well right now if you want you
can plug this into your controller
straight up guess I could work because
that's all I have to do to hear mine
since this feed only pumps out a clear
one that might be part of the issue
we'll see if that helps can you hear
yeah I just forgot how to adjust audio
it's control oh I never plug you in a
controller or a headset into this thing
that's fine it sounds quieter right a
little bit because I know this one's
always super loud yeah which is nice for
apex but it's weird I just wasn't
hearing directional audio
whoo man that alternator clip with no
extended mag this it's a bad time for
sure I'm constantly jumping around
trying to reload I reloaded three times
in that fight with race that's why I was
like she's ready I can't finish usually
told where people are by like where the
gunshots are coming from and I was
literally like spinning around like
where are these shots coming from I'm
trying to jump in ping at the same time
yeah I need to get a scuff so I can have
fluid pinging yeah it's go fizzle just
it's a must-have for me now like
whenever I have a regular controller I
just feel so handicapped like it doesn't
work for me I feel like I would only use
the paddles in this game for something
like looting like picking up the loo
yeah and pinging maybe jumping but yeah
probably nothing yeah I just like I have
it for looting sliding and jumping
mm-hmm it's really really useful
you know just hacking don't step on each
other's toes Oh double Mozambique ah
we're gonna win the mean team pick up
the gun thank you
you're an all-star popping already yeah
I hate that gun I'm sorry it's really
good up close but yeah the bullets are
so slow and I like that it has like
pretty much a massive clip - yeah yay
okay I can make this work
bass oh she's Rolo but she portal okay
are you serious that one all right there
we go
well I'm gonna get squished where is
your friend
oh no she's already dead Oh what kind of
what the hammer appointment I see
I thought you thirsted the first guy I
didn't really know I couldn't kill him
down here busting that Ulster yeah okay
where should we go
it's like alright if I see one I'll let
you know oh you need shield cells um let
me not hog all them sure it is littered
I am a litterer
why's it take me five years salute I
mean I look fast but I look horribly
that's the problem
not efficient at all there's no audio
wait you guys oh I forgot I think it's
from I think yours has to be not plugged
into your controller so that the stream
can hear the audio oh yeah I forgot
about that okay my got my bad guys
really yeah because when you plug it
it's the same as like the black magic
when you plug the headset into the well
that was awkward I'll just talking to
myself for like five minutes
no I think they can hear you but your
microphone problem your game my game
okay I feel like I heard somebody being
a ghost walking but I could be wrong
Oh
nevermind
I did care about me once it's mine
Oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
that must be this something in here yeah
cuz I heard that lifeline shooting me
and I did not hear the accelerant the
ultimate accelerant it just gives you
more percentage towards uh the ultimate
ability they buffed it from 25 percent
to 30 now there might be 35 even oh nice
honestly I always run straight past
those actually pretty useful depending
on situation yeah I feel like for people
who have damaging Ultimates like air
strikes and stuff well if you're Watson
you like absolutely have to
because you get it instantly yeah you
gonna hit them but I also to carry for
like crypto or like caustic because
their Ultimates are worthy all right I
haven't found my limit got about 20
minutes left of the stream here one for
every character without winning a single
toy is like the back of my hand
Riley might be gay nice dreams night a
bit there was in general a lot of teams
in that one area yeah and I really hate
that area because once you drop down
it's like looks fun over there that's it
anything
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
one of maybe two
all right here we go here we go that's
the first of many lights to go out all I
can fight already
I'm totally rockin a double hemlock
which is not a good idea for any sign of
movement edge of my toes right now bling
me I'm not a sweaty stream I'm sorry
unless Clips find a purple mag for that
spit firing I'll never have to reload
again that's where I'm at right now
yeah I saw them land in that building
every single time I split on his like
fine some little bit of loot off the
side that's when you get shot Josh I see
space earrings yet they didn't land here
max getting freaked out by a flag
relatable feeling
yeah that kind of moving right now
all right now I'm a shook because I
definitely saw this squad land in this
vicinity thanks for bringing me olives
I just heard like one little footsteps
all right you'd be surprised by how
scary some flags can be I like that they
add the lines so people know I'm not
shooting at an enemy did you get a gold
repo package coming yeah I'm like way
too let me Dinks myself all right I got
it
garbage done I've got art stars here so
throw in handle are you gonna cross I
don't know what I'm doing I was 12 so
they ran in that direction yeah oh I see
another squad Joe sporting someone out
there
we jump down that's good for us I'm
gonna yeah exactly
we out oh they're coming up
[Applause]
we just gotta watch our backs okay I
kind of want to get out of here yeah I'm
gonna need you to lower the Scoville
units just a tad here
I don't really have a sniper or anything
we're just training it's inside the
train station watching yeah they're fine
no they're the next ring is in that
direction
oh can we go through this way yeah let's
just let's just keep going around I kind
of want to make at least top five mm-hmm
going for a long game right here that
late game yeah
little alley we got here
yes enough space well take the guys room
just samuel l.jackson actually say that
hold on to your butt like Jack Black
would say I know 10 squats 117 people
including us so like 15 more people
flatlined Oh bless me word that would be
nice oh I have fun actually
there's a lot of death boxes in here
with item you should def just belt
second floor oh shoot
[Applause]
that was super close oh and then another
squad just came in and mowed them down
all right last one
yep last one hey we managed to get top 5
somehow somehow there was ten squads all
of a sudden there's five yeah just
because we circumvented that other fight
that was going to platinum hundreds I
didn't know there was an item or you can
revive yourself yeah that is the golden
knock down shields you can sell for
alive
it takes a long time it's pretty hard so
you actually get the revive off yeah but
it works
I got the need for speed we have no
choice but to win
yeah I've had enough enough of these MFE
third parties in this MFD game Samuel
Jackson so that's a real cool yeah red
retro says hey I'll watch a lot of you
babes love from India while sending that
lever back Asha thanks for joining us
let's see if we can get this w test for
you dropping it
I have the octane
the other great
why do I do this myself
I just go in the worst rooms possible
try to be an extra pair of ear at first
blood I'm like I hear them you're weird
I'm like pretty much different
I have a double top here platinum hunter
so is interesting because I just got
apex okay yeah so I gather cool thing
about a lot of the gold items that
you'll see once you start playing more
the gold items have like random perks
that are you can use equipment faster or
heal faster revive your teammate faster
what it's now once I cried II an angel
like if you were to have gone down what
happens I don't know the the perk is
that you heal the same speed but you
heal with half shields half health so
whereas you would only get revived with
like literally one whole yeah you would
get a little more health since I'm your
shields bags so more survivability
questions to start your your apex
journey let us know exactly I didn't
start right when this game came out I
started almost six seven months after oh
really yeah yeah sorta bottom the rings
closing in a minute
we're not close I'm actually not that
big on don't watch that much at which so
I wasn't like bombarded with all the
apex stuff right when it first came out
but let's explore this way I mean
oh good I really don't want this habit
but I have a lot of ammo for it yeah I
hate when I will like drop everything
for a gun that I want and then not find
any ammo I wonder why they took out the
turbo warehouse
show me the proof well we can't because
your bed and your aim that's not a good
judging factor developer say that to my
face I was just he just crouched down I
think he sees you and then I see someone
up there on top
[Music]
setting a portal here somebody else what
is that a revenant on top of that other
building
[Music]
[Applause]
I see a team overtime I somehow got a
total what the havoc you guys I don't
know how I did it yeah that is so
annoying I'm like I can't do that rings
closing in though take the zip line yeah
might be something good this way there's
a jump Tower here
are you still on there Hostel over there
well you want to trade a spring here
sorry loser too fast oh we can guard
this too
I kinda want to kill this guy says he's
been sittin I know a little gate keeper
yeah come on dude I mean we can't catch
him with the element of surprise cuz
he'll think we just we just yeah made a
run for it but there's also this other
side of the rock and yeah I could have
gone that way yeah I think you went that
way
shoot dang I wanted to shoot him really
bad Hanan the chats and the havoc isn't
bad when you know how to use it I agree
except I don't know how to use it the
super bad with it honestly I just I
panicked
[Music]
like finishing the job not enough in
that box like drop some for you thank
you all right we're still alive all
right let's select set for ring yeah
although I love playing wreath because
like when I'm running on rings pretty
close I always feel like sort of safe
yeah I know when somebody's looking at
me yeah you at least get a heads-up yeah
which is really good for looting on
console yeah you can't jiggle ooh rings
not too far 45 I don't know where it
goes
in the ring six squads left 12 people
including ourselves yeah we can do this
okay I don't know where even when you're
like calling it out I'm like oh my god
[Music]
oh no I'm getting stuck Oh God not not
like this right here
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
someone else got eyes on you max no I
set the portal around
[Music]
there's no select-fire anywhere I'm
still playing with a regular Prowler
oh I can finally switch out my havoc
which clearly did me in last game only
two other squads left to others clouds
remain okay we're gonna third party once
we hear bullets is not scared one reacts
pretty close or just hopefully they're
not going towards this you really don't
want to open up oh yeah they're going
for it
dang it I mean what should we do oh I
see another point all right so we got
eyes on one squad now we just gotta find
out where the other guys are what if
it's just one dude waiting oh like they
might decide slowly crawl away over
there
I'm a tree can't see tree
let's go this way we gotta get in the
ring anyway so might as well show me ten
seconds you're in close let's go let's
go let's go yeah I definitely want their
party this really bad well they picked
up something with it such a scavenger oh
man
okay okay my hands are sweating
mom spaghetti the whole thing yeah I
play this out I want to know where they
are right now we don't know where they
are and they aren't fighting each other
okay I see I only saw one person those
so far I don't see two people so I don't
know there might be another straggler I
also have my jump pad so if we need to
like make a quick getaway on top of
these things maybe or something but this
is gonna be out of ring okay one person
just hopped over to that side right I
just saw the other squad run across so
they might run into our other people
first okay I am just a sneaky sneak
sneaky sneak sneak sneak nobody sees me
I don't exist
oh there's a rep winning I am
oh I think they're near us yeah
did they see somebody else they're
firing on the other team I think yeah I
have my jumps half pad here 45 seconds
rings close oh right here
okay last quarter your squad Hills shoot
I fell down
are they I'm the second floor
[Music]
yet a gold
I shouldn't have shot him I should have
let him run the other guy didn't hear
him again she was melting but I don't
hear he's so lucky had that gold shield
because I lit him up dang well that was
going on second place
alright you guys thank you so much for
tuning in and watching us play some
duo's if you wanna play duo's it is now
live so grab a friend and try to be
number one but yeah thank you so much
hope you guys have a wonderful day
tomorrow is Thursday and we won't be
live-streaming playing a game but we
will have a live stream tomorrow for
something very special so make sure you
tune in for that and then of course
community Friday on Friday so thanks so
much for tuning in and we won't catch
guys next time
he's at
you
you